buongiorno ragazzi oggi facciamo una
cosa che volevo fare da un sacco di
tempo sia la burrobirra in passato l'ho
provata dagli harry potter studios a
londra
l'ho trovato una delle cose più
disgustose sono facce del pianeta ma
comunque pensato di provare a farla a
casa da solo ed è se questa che
effettivamente è uguale a quella che ho
assaggiato a londra dal presupposto che
la ricetta che ho assaggiato a londra
non è minimamente quella che tu leggi né
ibrim araba disgustosa mentre per quella
di oggi abbiamo un pochino guardato in
giro e ci siamo ispirati a una ricetta
che ha fatto cucina da uomini che tra
parentesi
saluto i miei vecchi amichetti e
compagni d'avventura con me oltre a
gianmarco oggi o un'ospite meravigliosa
perché stiamo parlando di di mia cugina
beatrice che è venuta a tema appena
saputo che facevo la burro benedetto
nostri capito da venire e quindi ho
deciso che anch'io dovrò mettermi a tema
per essere alla sua altezza
che cosa ci tiri fuori dal cappello
seguiti linea mia topaia devo ancora
fare un po di bianchi ok ok g che non ci
sia questa no è arrivato il suo cane
dell'inferno ancora devono disfare le
valigie dal mio ultimo carichissimo mi
solito la difendo con zoom è vero se
veramente non pensavo mettermi
innanzitutto essendovi fondo oro che
cosa e se qui grifondoro una sciarpa
sciarpa di grifondoro quello che rifondò
rover
mi pare di sì questa qui è una
grifondoro scanu fa la vuoi tu questa
scelta grifondoro no sì se se se la
fattura mettere i propri da roma costa
sciarpa verde enrico viii ai quad
esemplare di primitivo vorrei dire che
in passato mi hanno regalato non mi
ricordo chi una ragazza dei guanti
sempre ma essere crede ma non puoi
essere un miscuglio non l'ho mai mai mai
mai nemmeno tolti dal trustee china
anteriore come bandar testa di un tasto
rosso ma in realtà lui pure tyre è
scusata grifondoro io sono il tasto
rosso è vero domenica 3 verde chi erano
i grifondoro con una percentuale di
corvonero mentre voglia dire chi è la
nostra streghetta voglio aggiungere un
piccolo tassello per farlo dovrò
distruggere gli altri
mentre diventando troppo vivo in
compenso però voglia di un anno o di una
felix felici di caramelle tutti foschi 1
o di una truffa però man mano se buccino
bacchetta mi stai dicendo forse che non
una bacchetta in cambio un leviosa
bisogno di andare a cucinare ciao
ragazzi silente fa così e ne compaiono
le cose perché i poveri elfi o smigol
brontolo sotto a cucinare e quelli sopra
guarda che in realtà c'è una roba
pesantissima suoi reporter soler minace
letto se vuoi farmi assistente allora a
primi dello zucchero
per prima cosa io e la mia fedele amica
riunione mettiamo nello zucchero sicuro
che hermione non è più susan è quella di
tassorosso un po di acqua se ha
completamente devo fare un caramello po
di sale anche se scusami assistente c'è
se lei tifa per i ficus giocando sta
seguendo ma no non posso evitare di
trattare prima che brucia la cucina in
mano a dio come si si scioglievano
incantesimo mittente dai mi fa pena al
sun la bacchetta finite incantate
loro ci il burro da mettermi uno sblocco
di burro nella ricerca c'è scritto 6
cucchiai la ricetta in una segue in
realtà ci siamo ispirati per onestà e
mette un bel panetto fidati perché
bisogna fare del caramello è bellissimo
sul mare con la telecamera lo sarai mai
hanno visto che ti stai divertendo parti
ma la roma dovrà pagare il risultato
sembrava possiamo scrivere tutti quanti
bravo a gianmarco qua sotto se le sue
ripresi più di cominciano a migliorare
perché quella di nutella ammetto che sta
potremmo lam per ora il risultato è
questo chi stai dicendo che ti è bastato
così poco per far venire il risultato io
sono a me sembra un liquido è incerto
perché dobbiamo comunque unirlo alla
gazzosa c'è una ricetta da marco dieci
minuti sono un po sconvolto dal fatto
che sono riuscito a fare così
velocemente il caimano stato dimenticato
una cosa a un aroma di vaniglia un
piccolo no a ogni peggiore i genitori ne
sais felici o trendy ma perché quella
creatura alle nostre spalle ha così
perché c'è un po di morti dietro al clan
ecco diciamo che stando l'affare felice
lui è il simbolo delle vostre nozze
dai che nessuno sembra rallentato a casa
e riti chiamano arriva uno dei cuscini
che ti sta chiamando non s'è mai il suo
culo che sembra quasi che bello sembra
un miscuglio tra muco e piavè quindi
auto faccia qua devo dire che neville
paciock e susan possano mandare lavoro
tu con un camion canon arrivo sapete chi
è la zia march già ministro di mi chiedo
una cosa cosa
l'acceso bisogna vecchia dire pochissimo
non chiedermi perché chi non mettercela
ma dobbiamo montare la panna
apriamo io direi di non mettercela tutta
al qualora vada male perché va sempre
male ma perché dovrebbe andare male
ordine detto sto mai fermo così mi fermo
così perché lei appena detto
ma quando ti piace che si farà con il no
preferisci harry potter
preferisco hermione degli agitare e
colpire colpire capitol hai capito
adesso richiamo il cielo e iniziamo a
unire tutto quanto su usando ter domina
il caramello sta diventando leggermente
un ok un caramella mou si però noi
abbiamo la componente grassa del del
burro che non gli permette comunque di
cristallizzare grassissimo questo
qualcosa assieme
burro zucchero sì sì questa è la base
del bicchiere che adesso dopo subito a
comporre al caramello sul fondo
raccapricciante abbastanza dal mostruoso
preparatevi alla merkel a trovo
raccapricciante sta dicendo voglio
insieme con una bacchetta cinese perché
ormai si sa che la cina come andiamo a
girare la gassosa che aggiungiamo quindi
non c'è più la dentro lo zero cioè
l'unica nota positiva non e non c'è una
colica ma è grassissimo costoso ma lega
ma perché dure quando rimane adesso da
montare in un altro modo cosa sembra
commentate secondo me tipo stracciatella
panna venuta male stracciatella davvero
potete farlo a casa è svolta non sapevo
se dovesse nostra ma guarda che mi
fermerei così ma a nominare son contento
beh sì ragazzi questa è una burrobirra
che schifo una cosa che è bella da
vedere in realtà vero perché è
raccapricciante si bene o si mangia
questo caso si cagano andiamo di là al
primo assaggio perché essendo un sinuoso
sembra deliziosa la scusa ma mi sporco
anche a reporter si sporcano mentre è
bravo prova a prendermi la lega non so
cosa bella è stata terribile e buona
solo la palla sopra pandora ci dice cosa
ti piace io lo so e arriva il liquido
devi devi succhiare di risucchiare ok le
case poi fate queste facce io non
l'assaggio sembra nas susan io volevo
stare attento più grande propria piace a
me mi prendevo a casa vera anas ma piace
pensavo fosse peggio fate provava mai fa
venire da vomitare si fa schifo c'è un
animato sorso un percorso mai si è
diviso fa schifo la sento e la vaniglia
che da quel sapore che sembrano la
probabilmente acqua ha detto cioè
zucchero burro
secondo messa caramella
lo sa dell'odore e dello zucchero a velo
vanigliato ora sapevano magritte come è
arrivato ma va fatta diventare aggrega
poi vediamo se la bevanda non l'aveva
schifo assaporando la fa skifo xò primo
impatto non è così terremoti e
dolcissima allora ragazzi se l'ho
provato a casa fatemelo sapere
qua sotto o su instagram ancora meglio
spesso mi date nelle vostre stories è
bello riportarvi quindi lo faccio sempre
volentieri e che altro dire
questa mi è piaciuta questa ricetta
iscrivetevi a questo canale mettete rai
che cosa ne pensate nella nostra
meravigliosa susa possa o non è una
persona meravigliosa
detto ciò vi do un ma miano ricarda
sbatto astratto proprio l'altra comprate
ideologie adesso va beh ce n'erano
domani ciao